women get very forward with you which I
can only cover thought that my life on
stage apart from my mother yes yeah
on stage women can get just very alright
you're what you're saying I never said
this you're referring to the other day
someone screamed something in the
concert and then it went on YouTube and
yes it was because someone said in a
very polite way would you be interested
in exploring the possibility of perhaps
intercourse okay so here's what happens
someone I'm gonna clarify here a woman
it's a weird thing to scream
[Laughter]
Yoshi ran on stage and she grabbed the
mic right in front of State she just she
I saw we have a moment in our concert
where we we speak about being kind to
each other and how we see the world as
one place where we go to look off each
other and her response to that was great
act of kindness yeah think about it
worse things we could be doing it was
very lovely it was very lovely and and
it was just I had so I started this song
called ever grouse is this song about
you know um what I was talking about and
it was very quiet in the stadium but
this voice was so loud that I thought
everyone heard that and they probably
know that I heard it too so I had about
three bars of music where I was like
singing but thinking about her saying
[Laughter]
I'll stop the song and respond yeah it
was like a sort of aural Twitter yeah at
it tinder yeah you know crowd doesn't
know what you're talking about here
tonight so I'm I'm very quick for anyone
who shows up to our concerts and you
scream whatever you like yeah sure I
will not be screaming that okay I will
incredible eyes
you